Hey buddy!
Yeah!
I am so fucking tired right now.
As you guys know, I haven't slept yet.
I checked down two coffees, but I'm here.
I need to update you guys on life.
What the fuck do you mean you haven't slept?
Okay.
Okay, first off, there's two reasons.
I had to reset my sleep schedule again, because I fucked it up by working.
And then, two, I had a lot of work.
So, it's like, you know, you know, you know, when you're, you know, if you were like, you know, pre-debut VTuber...
you usually get, you know, a couple of months... I didn't get... I didn't have the luxury of a couple of months to come back here.
I had like, I don't know, you know, a couple of days... so I'm like... I'm like speedrunning stuff right now.
So, yeah, there's a lot.
But hey, it's crazy!
We have like...
We hit monetize- I was so surprised that we hit monetization.
We actually- okay, I didn't tell the story because like, we actually hit monetization.
Like, um, like, like being applicable to apply for monetization before my first stream.
Also, oh my god, thank you all for the super chats!
Holy shit, thank you everybo- my chat died.
There you- what the fuck?
Okay, um, oh my god, thank you!
Oh, my chat's fucking dead.
There- there's just too much stuff going on.
My chat has died now, okay.
Alright, okay, whatever.
Anyway, um, but yes, so like, I was applicable to apply for monetization before I even started my first stream.
And then after my first stream- okay, not even first, sorry.
My return stream.
I forgot there's other videos on this channel.
But anyway, after my return stream was done, like an hour or two later, um, I hit the, uh, they're like, you're monetized!
I was like, yay!
But there was a fucking catch.
Because whoever you were that fucking played Freebird in the middle of my stream!
Anyway, all proceeds of my return stream now goes to Freebird.
So, you know what?
Alright, to be fair, I had the option to mute Freebird.
But I had to- it was basically, like, if I mute Freebird, uh, we won't have the live chat replay.
I felt like, okay, this is good.
This is my first stream... return stream back.
So if I have a return stream back, I feel like we need to chat replay.
Because I figured... I found out... I was like, what the fuck is... where's my live chat replay?
So basically, if you try to mute... I thought it was like if you edit the vibe, you lose your live chat.
But apparently, if you mute your vibe or like anything regarding muting or replacing the audio, it counts as removing the live chat.
So I was just like, alright, we'll just... alright, you know what?
You deserve the money.
It's fine.
You deserve... I was just like, it's fine.
You deserve it.
How did it...
play?
Well, I haven't touched the settings on my stream labs for a very long time.
And I forgot when I used to stream on Twitch, I had people submit like audio... like they can submit audio clips.
Or you guys can't do that here now because I replaced my alert box to my YouTube now.
So the alert box is not connected to my stream... like not connected to my Twitch stream labs anymore.
So now you can't fucking play Freebirds on stream anymore.
So this bot...
won't get demonetized.
I hope.
So we don't have to worry about demonetization via Freebirds.
So yeah.
I can't believe I got... this is exactly why I am fu... we were never gonna be Freebirds.
We're never going to be fucking Freebirds.
Because my return stream is demonetized.
Um...
But yeah.
Oh my god.
There has been... I've been doing...
so much stuff.
Okay.
So...
It was a little bit naive of me to think...
That like... I was like...
Man... 50 orders...
is going to be a lot.
I was like... Oh my god.
If I get like...
just a little above 50 orders...
in the merch store...
That would be good enough for me.
Little do I know...
It was a little bit over 50.
You know?
I was like...
I literally...
put up the limited bundle...
for like...
less than 5 minutes...
and it was just gone.
I was like...
What?
I refreshed it.
I was like...
Huh?
Wait...
And then...
By the way...
Sorry I shot myself in the foot there.
Because like... the...
personalized messages...
I was going to write...
each postcard was going to be like...
a unique message for me.
And now I'm like... Okay.
It's 100 postcards.
That'll be fine.
I can just do this like...
It'll be a build up.
Now it's 200.
Oh my god.
Okay.
We'll make it through.
But yes.
This is like my first time opening...
my own big store.
So like...
It was so fucking naive of me...
to think that...
I was like... Okay.
We can open a store...
within like...
Because you know how you guys might think...
Oh she must have been planning on opening a store...
like... since like... 5 days.
I don't know.
When did I lost my job?
Sorry.
You know like...
You know...
That day.
But no.
It was...
2 hours.
2 hours...
before...
Uh...
2 hours before my return stream.
I was like... Mr. Man!
I don't have time to prep for my return stream...
and do my store.
Can you do the store?
And Mr. Man was like... Yeah.
I think I can do it.
And I was like... Mr. Man!
Do you think you can get it done while I'm streaming?
And he was like... Yeah.
And little did we know...
Running a store...
and getting a...
was...
Not knowing how many people were...
actually buying...
the products...
It was... It took longer...
than... you know...
It definitely took much longer...
than 4 hours to set...
everything up.
In fact...
It's crazy that we...
didn't manage to set all of this up...
within 3 days.
So...
So like... Okay.
When we launched it...
For some reason... The shipping thing...
Yeah.
How hard could it be?
You know?
It was...
It was pretty difficult.
I...
It was...
It was pretty difficult.
Like... Yeah.
It was...
Okay.
So...
You know... Store launched...
And then we realized... The shipping...
was like... connected...
to...
Like... The shipp... When you buy a sticker...
For some fucking reason...
The shipping for stickers...
was like... $20.
And I was like...
Wait... That's not right...
I was like... I was like...
Uh... Mr. Man...
I'm getting reports that... Shipping is...
$20...
For a sticker...
And then...
It was...
My decision...
To pull the store down...
Immediately after we figured...
Found out... Because like... Mr. Man was like...
Oh yeah... We can try and fix it while the store is still up...
I was like... No...
Shut it down... Now... We need to fix this...
Cause like... I think like... At first we thought it was gonna be a quick fix...
But then like... We realized...
Wait... This is not a quick fix...
And I didn't wanna...
I really... Like... I really didn't wanna like...
Um...
Overcharge people...
On shipping as well...
Because like... Um...
I know how much shipping costs...
And... I just... I just didn't wanna...
Overcharge you guys for like...
These items... Cause like... You know...
You're willing to buy from me...
And you're willing to like...
Spend your money on me and everything...
And like... I don't wanna fucking... Like...
Um...
Overcharge you on the shipping... I want like... A fair price...
And then... Mr. Man was like...
You might have a loss if you don't know exactly...
Like... Like the shipping...
Thing... And I was like... I rather...
I rather take a tiny loss...
In shipping...
Um... Or instead of like...
Overcharging all of you guys...
Uh... In shipping...
And getting like... A... Like... A necessary profit...
From the shipping itself...
Um... So I wanted to make it...
As fair as possible...
Because I've like... Shipped pro...
I shipped products...
Uh...
Since I was a middle schooler...
And like... I've sold things since I was a middle schooler...
So I know like... The exact prices...
Of actual like...
Uh... Postal cost and everything...
So like... Cause like... Um...
Sometimes like... The weight...
Doesn't really correlate with like...
How much it actually costs at the post office...
So... I knew like...
Like... I... Because I had experience...
Shipping things... I knew like...
Yeah... That's not the actual...
Like... Price with the weight...
And like... I... Cause like...
Charms... It was like...
One charm... Like on the website...
One charm...
It... It made it... For Canadian shipping...
It was like...
$19...
Canadian...
And I was like... Okay... That's not right...
I was just like...
Wait a minute...
It should not be $19...
For one charm...
I was like... Okay... Wait...
A minute... But then...
I was like... Yeah...
That's a problem...
Originally... The... Um...
The bundles...
Was like... $60...
I was like... Wait a minute...
I know...
For sure...
It is not $60...
I was like...
In the United States... Cause like...
It's like... A...
Dokimakura cover...
With like... A quick charm...
And a quick stand...
I was like... There's no fucking way...
It's $60 to the United States...
I was like... I've shipped these before...
I... There's no...
Unless... Canadian...
Canada Post is like...
Fucking bankrupt...
Like... Inflation...
In the past 2-3 years...
Like... Okay... The Canadian dollar is...
Fucking garbage...
But it's not that bad...
Where it takes $60 fucking dollars...
To send to America...
Like... At that point...
Why the fuck are we living in Canada?
We should like... Not even sell anything...
To the States... Cause it's not even worth it...
Um...
But yeah... Anyway...
So... We had all...
So that's why it took us like...
4 to...
4 to 5 hours...
Cause we have to go through like...
Individually... Of like all...
The items to make sure...
Um...
To make sure...
Everything was like... Reasonable?
Um... Everyth...
No stop insulting...
Canada...
Look...
Look all Canadians...
Including myself will agree with me...
Um... Anyway...
So... Like...
We've accepted our...
We've accepted our place...
In the world... Um... But yeah...
So like... I tried really hard...
And then... And then after the shop...
Went back live... My mom came in and was like...
Was like...
Your shipping is too cheap...
My mom came in...
And was like... What are you doing?
What if...
What if it's too cheap?
And I was like... No... Don't worry...
I... Don't worry...
Um...
But yes... So... We've...
Expanded... Uh...
We've expanded our team...
Our... Uh... Mr. Man team...
So now we have...
Mr. Man... Little Man...
And Consult Man...
So like... We... At first...
So it was gonna be Mr. Man...
And Little Man... And Little Man was...
Recruited... Uh... Because they have...
Experience running... Uh... Shopify...
Um...
And so... And they...
Wrote... Like all the terms of service...
And are doing customer support...
And... Like the...
Privacy policy... They wrote all of that...
And then... So then... But then when we...
Did our first... Launch...
Uh... The first launch... That was at...
12... Uh... We realized...
That like... There were problems...
There were issues with like... Worldwide shipping...
And... Um...
And everything... So then we...
Uh... Mr. Man recruited...
Consult Man... So...
Consult Man... Um... Is also...
Used to work at Shopify...
And they also like... Was helping us figure out...
Why we weren't doing... We weren't...
Able to have worldwide shipping...
As well as like... Like you know... Like the credit card issue...
Apparently... Uh... For those who are...
Wondering why your...
Your country isn't in... Um...
Isn't... Uh...
In like the shipping stuff...
Yet... It's like... It's like a gradual thing...
So later on... They'll like...
You'll... It's like a Shopify thing...
So later on... More and more countries...
Will be like... Eligible... Um...
So it just takes a gradual time...
Um... And I wanna say like...
A huge thank you to the team...
Because they're working incredibly hard...
And they're like... Updating everybody...
On... Um...
They're like updating everybody...
Uh... On...
Uh... Twitter... As well as like emails...
For anyone that had questions... Like...
And anything... And they're like updating on...
Like... On real time too... So they're trying to...
Make sure everybody... Uh...
Receives their order... And everything...
Uh... And also like...
Uh... During those times...
They like... Refunded everybody that accidentally paid...
Uh...
The $20 shipping for one sticker...
Like...
They like... Refunded... Oh my god...
They like... Refunded...
Like... Oh my gosh... Wait... I can actually...
I can see it right now... How many orders they had to...
Refund... Because like... We didn't wanna like...
Scam anybody... I know some of you guys are like...
No... Take my... Overpriced... Fucking shipping...
No... Please... I...
No... Don't do that to yourself...
Please... Love yourself...
Like I eventually did...
But like... We refunded like... 480 orders...
Um...
That accidentally paid way too much...
Than it should be... Um...
And everything... Um...
By the way... I... Also thank you again everybody...
For the super chat... I can't believe it...
For those who are wondering why I haven't opened up...
Uh... Memberships yet...
Oh sorry... Ambership...
Sorry for those who have...
Wondering why I haven't opened...
Amberships yet...
Um... It is because... Um...
I had to do this...
I had to do the...
Merch stuff... So...
Uh... There's a lot of work into like...
Getting everything for the...
Amberships... So I couldn't...
Uh... I didn't really have the time to...
Because you have to write a lot of stuff...
And I was like... Oh my god...
There's not enough time...
There's not enough time right now... But anyway...
Um...
Fuck... What was the story before?
Fuck... Okay... Anyway... Regarding the story...
Uh... The funny thing...
Is that... Oh no... It's not funny...
But like... Okay... It's a little funny...
I was like... Freaking out... Because I am a huge...
Perfectionist... So I was like...
What the fuck is going on?
And I was like... Why are they...
Paying $20...
For shipping... For a...
Fucking sticker...
And then like... I was like...
Take the site down... Now...
I don't wanna scam... I don't wanna...
Scam anybody... Like...
Um... They gave so much to me...
I don't wanna... I wanna make sure everything is...
Fair... And then...
Um... And then I was like...
I was like... Like... I'm sorry...
Mr. Man... For... For being...
So harsh... Like...
I was just very overwhelmed...
And... I also...
Did not sleep... At all...
And then... Um...
You know what Mr. Man said?
Mr. Man was like...
Don't worry... I've managed...
XQC...
This is nothing...
He was like...
No matter what... I'll never...
Reach that level...
So I was just like...
Oh shit... You know what?
You're right... No matter what I say...
To you... You've already been...
Hardened by your time...
Managing...
XQC... He doesn't manage...
Him anymore... He used to be...
His manager...
So I was just like...
I was just like... You know what?
You're right...
No matter what... I would...
Never... I would...
Never be as bad...
When it comes to that...
Um... So...
I was like... Oh thank god...
Anyway... The team...
I'm just really thankful... Because Mr. Man has like...
A lot of experience...
And a lot of like...
Uh... A lot of like...
I guess like experience and connections...
And everything... Because...
When we brought in Consult Man...
Because I was like...
No the shipping... The shipping has to be...
Cheaper... I can't deal with...
I know... Because at first...
After we got rid of $20...
We went with $17...
And then I was like... No!
That is still too expensive!
But it was on the...
Shopify thing... Like the...
Shopify was like...
Defaulting to that... And then...
Um...
And then... I was... And then they were like...
But it's gonna be a lot... So I was like... No!
I know...
Stickers are not fucking...
$17...
Because it's literally paper...
Where the fuck...
Is the weight in fucking...
Paper... So then...
Um... Consult Man was helping with like...
The Shopify thing... And then they were like...
No you have... Like... And then...
When I had so many questions and stuff like that...
And then... Uh...
Consult Man... Um... Actually...
It works for Ludwig...
Um... And...
Uh... They were like...
Don't worry... Consult Man has experience...
And then I was like... Yeah...
But Ludwig doesn't sell VTuber...
Products...
I was like...
I don't think Ludwig sells VTuber...
Products...
And I know paper is not...
$17...
So...
Um...
So like...
I was like... Please...
Trust me on this... Like... I know...
You work for Ludwig... But please...
Trust me on this... It has to be...
Two or three dollars...
Cause like... It's paper...
...
Um... So that's why...
Now... Like... Uh...
The stickers are...
For shipping is...
Uh... What could if he was...
Based... Uh... Yeah...
I guess... The Ludwig...
Documacura...
I don't know... I don't...
I don't know about that...
Um...
So yes... The... It is...
It is a team... But I really do...
Appreciate... I really do appreciate...
The Man team...
Being... Made...
And... Uh... And Mr. Man...
Recruiting... Uh...
Two very... Very... Very... Talented...
Individuals... That... Definitely...
Know what they're doing... They fucking...
Opened a store in three...
Days... That's...
Like... Despite... Some...
Scuff... Um...
And like... You know... Some bugs and stuff...
Um... This is the first time...
We like... Open...
Like... For me... I opened something...
Like this... So...
Um... Like I've done like small scale...
So like... I've never done...
Something this big... And like...
Yes... Graphic design is...
Mr. Man's passion... Uh...
Hahaha... But...
I swear... It will look like...
A real website soon...
We just didn't have the time...
To set that up... Um...
So like... At first...
Uh... Mr. Man made the header...
And it just says...
No head... Because the...
The ER got cut off...
And then... It was...
On screen... And then my...
My friend... One of my friends...
Sent me a screenshot and was like...
What the fuck... Why does this...
Seem real...
I was just like...
Oh fuck...
Wait... Can you fix that...
Real quick... Um...
But yes... Now...
Now it says... No header...
Don't worry... We're...
Family friendly... As could be...
We're... We're not too kid friendly...
So that... I still am monetized...
But we are...
We are PG-13...
We're PG-13... Uh...
Also... Thank you guys so much for the super chat...
Thank you... Thank you... Thank you everybody...
For the Akasupas...
It really... Really... Really means...
So much guys...
Thank you everybody for the support...
Oh my god...
Um... But yeah...
It's been like... It's been so...
Crazy... I...
Ohhhhh...
It's been like...
So fucking crazy...
The last couple of days...
I've been like non-stop working...
I've recently just hired... Um...
Some editors...
That will start... Uh... Working on...
Um... Shorts again...
Um... I'm reaching out to some animators...
Um... I finished my schedule...
Yesterday night...
That's one of the reasons why I haven't slept...
I was... Um... Finishing up...
My schedule... Yesterday night...
And... Uh...
And... Oh my god... There's so many things...
There's so many things I have to do...
For Mr. Man as well...
There's so many things... There's...
I... I wish I could tell you guys...
What the fuck is going on...
Behind the scene...
I wish I could... There's like...
So many things I really want to talk to you guys...
But there's... There's like...
So many...
Sponsors...
And like... Conventions...
Like... People that reached out...
And... I like cried last night...
I... I... I... I cried...
Last night... Cause... The support...
Like... Okay... To be fair... I cried every... I cry every day...
After everything I went through...
I like... Cry every day...
But like... Last night I cried...
Like... Happy tears...
Because I was just... So...
Like... Overwhelmed...
With everything... And overwhelmed...
With all the support...
And...
It was just... Crazy...
Like... All the things... All the...
Opportunities... And everything... I really...
I really did not...
Expect... All these...
Opportunities... Just...
Um...
Like... Of all these opportunities...
Of people reaching out to me...
It was just... It was just...
Crazy... And then...
Oh my gosh... And then like...
Like Mr. Man was like...
Um...
Oh...
Cause I was like...
Thank you again to...
Mr. Man for like... Doing all of this...
And... Because like... You know...
He... This isn't even his like...
Managing me isn't even...
His like... Main job...
He... He's like...
Doing this... Like...
On the side for me... But he's already...
Giving like... He gave like...
5 hours...
Like non-stop of trying to...
Fix the store and bringing...
Two very talented...
Individuals to help settle everything...
For the store and like... Communicating...
With people and everything...
Regarding like... Like... Their orders...
And all that stuff... And...
Um... You know this isn't even...
His like... Main job...
So... I was just like...
And then he's like... I was like... Thank you again...
And he's like... Um...
He's like... Um...
I like you as a person and I'll give you...
My 110%.
And I'm like...
No...
AHHHHHHHHH!
Hahahaha...
Hahahaha... I was like...
AHHHH!
WHYYYYY?!
Um... But...
Yeah... It's actually... It's... It's...
That's so fucking crazy.
Sorry, I had to like calm down a little bit.
I had to calm down.
Oh my god.
I know some of you guys are like, Where's our gaming stream?
Another Zatsudon?
Another chatting stream?
Guys, soon.
Soon, as I said, our first gaming stream is going to be Neopets.
Guys, don't worry.
That's going to be happening next week.
Tomorrow, we will be celebrating Lunar New Year.
I think it's going to be like at 5pm PST tomorrow.
We're going to be celebrating Lunar New Year.
And then, I think I'll be opening my membership tomorrow as well.
Because I want to do Garfield Cart next week.
I want to do Garfield Cart next week in members.
So I really want to open my membership by then.
So we can...
We can play Garfield Cart.
Um...
And...
Yeah, like...
There's just...
There's so many things going on.
But yes, thank you everybody for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you everyone for the support.
And thank you everybody for just...
Ah, it's just crazy.
It's still...
It's still super surreal and everything.
Um...
That's going on.
And also for those who are like, Are we getting our names yet?
Are we going to...
Are we going to be finally named?
Um...
No.
I'm sort of enjoying guys like battle royaling out right now.
And like fighting each other on which is the best name to represent you guys.
And also like I feel like I'm way too tired to pick a name today.
I did not...
I did not really have a chance to like actually look through all the names.
So I'm going to give you guys one more day.
And tomorrow on Lunar New Year.
Yes, you guys are nameless for another day.
So you guys are nameless for another day.
You guys still have to fight each other for one more day.
Because by God, I love seeing you all fight.
And...
Um...
But tomorrow we're going to not only decide the name.
But also we are going to be...
Finally I'm going to draw you guys.
We're going to draw a mascot.
A fan mascot to represent all of you tomorrow as well.
So that's what to look forward to.
You know what?
I'll tell you guys my schedule.
I fucking worked all night on it yesterday night.
So I might as well tell you guys my schedule.
Anyway, so...
Um...
Obviously, we're going to have Neopets on...
I'm taking Sunday off.
Because holy fuck.
I hope I reset my schedule by then.
But Monday is going to be Neopets at 5pm PST.
Tuesday will be the new season Apex launch.
I actually play tested this!
Oh my God!
Keeping that a secret for so long.
And like I also saw...
I was...
They invited me to see...
Like look at like the updates and everything.
So I actually...
I waited so long to be like...
I was there!
I play tested!
I tested...
Um...
All the updates for the new season.
And...
That was...
I'm...
It's going to be great.
It's going to be...
Haha!
It's like...
They were...
Wait, did they...
Okay, I don't actually know what's actually been announced.
On what...
Okay.
The actual...
The Apex players out there.
What did they announce?
Because I didn't read any articles.
I know they announced some stuff of what's going to be in the new season.
But like...
I don't know how to read.
That's my...
Mr. Man's job.
Uh...
So like...
What did they already tell you guys?
Because I don't want...
Like...
Oh no!
Doki...
We can't invite Doki anymore.
Because...
Because she...
She...
She leaked the fucking Apex patches before it came out.
Oh, they showed the perks?
Yeah!
So it's like MOBA-ish.
Okay.
So...
It's basically like...
Uh...
The MOBA...
Like MOBA stuff.
So like you didn't get to pick the...
The upgrades and stuff like that.
And it's...
It's like...
Um...
It's...
It's very fun.
It's very interesting.
And very fun.
Um...
I was able to test that out.
Playtest that.
And I'm so happy it's finally live.
Uh...
Because I've been waiting to see that on live for so long.
Anyway!
But also!
The best part!
I can finally play Warner Brothers.
I can finally play these games.
Because...
What can they do to me?
Which means!
I can finally play Batman Arkham Asylum!
Which is a game I've been wanting to play for fucking ever!
I've never played any...
I actually...
I very much...
Very much enjoy like DC.
Like I am a...
Like...
I'm sorry for all you like Marvel fanboys out there.
But like I'm not like a...
I don't really like Marvel lore much.
I very much enjoy...
I always...
I talked about this before.
But I enjoy like DC comics and the DC movies.
The anime ones.
Like not the live action.
That...
That shit was just a little too sad.
Because Warner Brothers is now owned by someone that doesn't really give a fuck about good movies.
Like...
So...
The new...
I can say it now!
What is he gonna do?
Try and delete my channel like they did to Wile E.
Coyote?
But anyway...
For tax breaks?
But anyway, yeah like...
I really do enjoy the anime.
The animated...
The animated DC movies and the...
And like just the comics from DC as well.
So...
I'm so happy!
I can finally play Backman Arkham Asylum.
It's actually one of the games I've been dying to play for the longest time.
No!
Who can stop me?
He's too busy dealing with like real matters.
Like finding ways to...
To get more tax breaks.
Like who the fuck cares about this random anime girl?
Um...
Anyway...
Uh...
Yeah, that's gonna be on Tuesday.
So it's gonna be like the Apex launch and also Batman Arkham Asylum.
And...
Uh...
And then!
On February 14th, it's time to celebrate a very important holiday.
I hope you guys did not forget.
But it is...
Happy Anniversary!
It's Amber's Day!
It's gonna be his birthday!
Because that's the most important holiday.
So February 14th is Amber's birthday.
And then on the 15th, we are going to have an Apex collab with Ditto.
And question mark, question mark, question mark third.
Um...
It might be Uto.
I'm not sure yet.
So...
Uh...
We're confirming that today.
And then Friday...
We're gonna be doing Inside the Backrooms with Usan.
Um...
And finally, Saturday is...
Members Garfield Card!
Yay!
The one to look forward to the most!
Yeah!
Um...
So...
It's a packed week.
I've...
I fucking miss streaming so much.
So...
I was so ready to like...
Pack it up with everything.
And...
Uh...
I'm just...
I'm just so happy to be streaming again.
It's actually...
I'm just really, really, really, really happy...
To stream again.
And...
Just talk to you guys.
Um...
And everything.
You guys have no idea how much I miss this.
Holy shit.
I...
It's just...
I'm just so happy to be able to do this again.
Um...
And I'm so tired too.
I'm so...
I'm on like...
I don't know if it's like noticeable.
But like...
I'm on two cans of coffee right now.
I'm so fucked up right now.
I'm actually so fucked up right now.
Oh my god.
I'm...
Oh my god!
I can play so many stupid fucking games too.
Holy shit.
It's...
I can actually just be like...
What do I wanna play today?
And it'd be like...
Whoa!
This game...
Or that game...
Is actually crazy.
I...
Knowing what I can play now...
How do I play later?
And then...
Oh my gosh.
I'm planning where in my channel is gonna be heading to.
Like...
Recently I've been like...
Hitting up some animators and stuff like that.
And...
Like I said like shorts are coming back very very very very soon.
Just...
Just setting up the server for my editors.
And...
Ah!
There's so much to look forward to and then I have to...
I have to fucking make a proposal thing for Mr. Man on like all the tournaments and projects and events I want to do as well.
So I have to do that too.
It's like every day there's so much work.
And honestly I... oh my gosh I'm the happiest when I get to just work.
I am just such a workaholic and it's crazy.
I can't believe my therapist is gonna be like, Wow Doki you're...
My therapist is gonna enjoy hearing this because before all of this, all my therapist heard was me being like, I'm so fucking sad.
Before all this, all he heard was just me being like, I'm sad, I'm angry, I'm empty inside.
And now...
NOW!
Now!
Now it's gonna be different!
Instead it's gonna be like, I'm stressed.
There's so much work.
I haven't been sleeping.
Oh my god.
But thank you everybody.
Thank you everyone for all the super chats guys and all the people that ordered merch.
Oh I can't...
I'm so...
I'm just...
I'm just so excited.
Um...
And I...
I...
Like I...
I know I keep saying it but...
You guys just give me so much hope right now.
And...
It's just...
It's just crazy.
I never expected to see all this support.
And I know I keep saying it but like I need to say it again and again because...
It feels so fucking surreal right now and...
I'm just so happy.
I...
I haven't been happy for a long time.
And I'm...
I'm happy.
I'm happy right now.
But also I have an underlying fear or two.
I do.
I do have an underlying fear.
And I'm like, what if I fail?
That's scary.
Oh my god.
Um...
But yeah.
Anyway.
I was so...
I was just so...
So surprised like...
Uh...
Like all the people...
Like just the talented team that's helping me too.
It's actually insane and how on top of things they are.
Oh...
Thank you everyone.
Anyway.
That's really all I want to say.
I really just wanted to update you guys on like what the fuck is going on right now.
And like I felt really bad that like I didn't like really...
I know like I just got back and then I was like I need a stream.
I really fucking need to stream.
And then I was like okay I finished the store.
Okay now I can stream because like I was like...
I thought...
I didn't know when the store was actually going to come back.
So I was just like okay we got...
We gotta figure all this out before I put a stream time.
Because I'm worried that we're gonna still be working on the store afterwards.
But now it's done.
And I was like okay I need to give them a life update.
I need to let them know like what's going on in my life now.
Um...
But yes I know on the other side of the world there's also Lunar New Year right now.
Yeah!
Congratulations everyone.
See you soon.
But yes Happy Lunar New Year on the other side of the world.
Um...
I'll be celebrating Lunar New Year on my end.
Uh...
For tomorrow because that's when it's Lunar New Year tomorrow.
So um...
I can't wait to celebrate all of that with you guys.
And that's also when we are uh...
Deciding on finally the name.
And also what you guys look like.
So I'm gonna be drawing you guys as well for tomorrow.
Um...
And everything.
So that's what to look forward to.
But yes.
Thank you again.
I know this is such a super duper uh...
Super duper short stream.
Um...
But...
I'm gonna fucking pass out.
We're not going to fucking...
Because those two cups of coffee...
It's hitting...
The...
The crash is hitting very very soon.
It's hitting very very soon.
I could...
I could feel it right now.
And like...
I need you guys to know...
We are not fucking being freebirds.
Because of what the fu- Because of what freebirds did to my stream.
But...
I was...
At first I was like...
Mmm...
Maybe we won't be freebirds.
But now...
Definitely not freebirds.
Um...
But yes.
Thank you everybody.
I'm so sorry this is like an incredibly short stream.
I did want to do a longer one today.
But like...
You know...
Me drinking two cups of coffee...
To be like...
No I'll be fine.
The truth is...
It was not funny.
It was not...
It was not a good idea.
But thank you everyone.
Thank you again for all the super chats everybody.
Thank you.
I wish I could thank you guys individually.
But thank you all.
And thank you all for purchasing the merch as well.
I really...
Really do appreciate it.
Um...
And...
Yeah.
Happy Lunar New Year.
For those who are celebrating it right now.
And thank you.
Thank you.
I really...
I feel like every time I say thank you, it would never be enough.
But I just want you guys to know.
Like...
Thank you.
Anyway guys.
I'm gonna fucking pass out now.
As always everyone.
Stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stayed up for me.
Head to bed.
Cause you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time everybody.
Bye guys.
Bye.